if you think you suck as you sit here
today I want you to understand something
that was somebody else's voice putting
that inside of your head that person
felt sucky about themselves too
something I'm about to start making a
lot of content around is called [__]
your grandparents
yep new big pillar for me coming in
2024. whole framework it's called [__]
your grandparents let me tell you why so
many people in here running around with
so much [__] anger and hate towards
their mom and their dad
and given granny a pass when she was the
one that [__] made them
so many people in this room mad as
[__] daddy when daddy's dad [__]
them the [__] up
so a lot of you love grandma she gave
you some cookies and [__] hate your
[__] mom but the grandma was the
[__] problem but here's where it gets
interesting 2026 I'm coming out with
[__] your grandparents parents
my friends
how about instead of being really
[__] mad at your parents then moving
that on to hating the [__] out of your
grandparents then deciding your great
grandparents were the actual [__] and
then starting some weird [__] family
tree [__] hate framework how about we
start deploying compassion how about you
start feeling bad for your mom and dad
how about the people here that haven't
talked to a relative a brother a sister
a cousin a mom or an aunt how about you
leave vegan and [__] call them and
say I'm sorry because this [__] doesn't
actually [__] matter
[Applause]